hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
the issue of plastic pollution has been
making the rounds in the news lately but
what can we do about it
and what is being done about it now in
this video we'll take a look at the
drastic amounts of plastic pollution
particularly in the ocean we'll also
look at the effects that it's having on
our bodies and the environment and
lastly we'll finish off of the featured
story of this video how scientists
managed to figure out how to turn
plastic waste into jet fuel it's going
to be an interesting video so let's take
a look you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
from grocery bags to plastic straws to
tiny micro beads and everything from
soap to make up the earth is swamped in
plastic and will remain so for
generations to come so how much plastic
is there well there's been around a 6.3
billion tons of plastic produced
worldwide since the 1950s looking at
this graph you can see the clear uptrend
in plastic production but interestingly
the effect of the 2008 financial crisis
can also be seen of this an estimated 8
million tonnes of plastic wind up in the
oceans every year and is pervasive the
World Economic Forum predicts that by
2050 if things continue at the current
rate the oceans will hold more plastic
waste than fish at the bottom of the 11
kilometer deep Mariana Trench the
deepest part of the explored ocean
plastic waste has been found three times
one of the most personal examples of
plastic waste in the ocean is the Great
Pacific Garbage Patch it's a collection
of plastic and floating trash which
mainly comes from countries in Asia
there's an estimated 1.8 trillion pieces
of plastic here there's also a North
Atlantic Garbage Patch which is also
growing all of this isn't to mention the
effect that is having on wildlife
already this isn't great but it gets
worse a recent study found that we're
eating our own plastic waste in fact
every week we eat enough plastic to make
a credit card annually we eat about 250
grams this study was carried out by the
University of Newcastle and they stayed
that the most common source of plastic
consumption is drinking water this
includes tap water or bottled water fish
unsurprisingly was another source but
interestingly the other two biggest
culprits were salt and beer a lot is
unknown about plastic consumption and
its effects in humans but a certain
chemical found in some plastics called
BPA has been shown to reduce sperm count
apart from all of this the main problem
with plastic is that it just doesn't
break down it's estimated that a foam
plastic carp will take 50 years a
disposable nappy 450 years and a fishing
line 600 years to degrade so don't lose
hope yet will soon take a look at what's
being done about this issue towards the
end of the video but first we should
take a look at who exactly are the
biggest plastic polluters and where
exactly is the source of all this
plastic waste coming from let's take a
look at the data so the question must be
asked who is the biggest contributor to
plastic waste so looking at this chart
we can see who the biggest polluters
number one is China number two
Indonesia number three the Philippines
number four Vietnam and number five sri
lanka but note that this was in 2010
just as china was starting their
transformation into an industrial
economic superpower from this time
China's industrial output has grown
exponentially it said that in this
expansion Chinese does much concrete as
the United States did during the entire
20th century but anyway overall the
situation is a bit more complex as the
United States consumes a lot of goods
produced in the East so one can't really
exist without the other
in some good news China is now making
strides to solve these issues and has
reported a 66% drop in the amount of
plastic bags used in the past year about
40 billion bags weren't used so what are
the areas that this plastic waste is
coming from well according to a 2017
study about 90 percent of all plastic
pollution comes from just ten rivers
eight in Asia and two in Africa so what
sectors are producing the most plastic
well by far and away its packaging
packaging leaves by two times the next
biggest category which is building and
construction ok so this sounds all
pretty bad but let's get to the good
news about how we can fix this problem
so slowly was started taking a look at
this chart in 1980 about a hundred
percent of plastics was discarded as
waste and then in the early 1980s
incinerating started to become practice
then in the late 1980s recycling was
brought into the picture and today about
45 percent of old plastic waste is
either recycled or incinerated not
perfect but it's better than ending up
in the ocean in terms of our recycling
rate which is one of the key parts of
this entire debate because in theory if
we could successfully recycle our
plastics and we wouldn't have a plastic
problem a lot of experts I talked to
insists that we don't have a plastic
problem we have a waste problem as shown
by this graphic compared to the sheer
amount of plastic produced it seems that
our recycling efforts may just not be
enough to solve this problem in a timely
manner
we could demand legislation to curb the
production of plastics but we could also
look to technology to help one team of
engineers took this task seriously and
developed a massive cleaning device to
take on the great Garbage Patch in the
ocean that I talked about earlier
unfortunately in January 2019 the device
did break down and had to be repaired
but it's being relaunched later this
year perhaps it's better to engineer
projects on a smaller scale these can
have an impact on a smaller localized
area - rubbish sucking sea bins were
recently installed in Sydney Harbor the
devices suck in water trapping rubbish
in a mesh bag and recirculate the water
back into the environment there are 450
C bins in 26 countries around the world
collecting around 4 kilograms a day or
1.4 tonnes a year
another small ocean cleaner known as mr.
trash will is making a difference in the
United States as the wheel turns it
collects litter from the harbor and
stores it in the barge later for removal
they're also legislative actions being
taken we all know about straws being
banned in places and a lot of store
outlets have banned single-use plastic
bags in May of 2019 a new model of
collecting packages from consumers began
it's called loop some big name partners
include Procter & Gamble Nestle PepsiCo
Unilever The Body Shop coca-cola and
other firms
but what if we could do even more than
all of this what if we could turn
plastic waste into fuel and here we come
to our featured story a research group
led by the Washington State University
has found a way to turn daily plastic
waste into jet fuel in a new paper
published in the Journal of Applied
energy the scientists melted plastic
waste at high temperatures with
activated carbon basically processed
carbon with increased surface area and
the end result was jet fuel so here's
how it works in the experiment the
scientists ground down waste plastic
products like water bottles milk bottles
and plastic bags down to about three
millimeters or about the size of a grain
of rice the plastic granules were then
placed on top of activated carbon and
achieve reactor at a high temperature of
about 571 degrees Celsius the carbon is
a catalyst or a substance that speeds up
the chemical reaction without being
consumed by the reaction itself project
lead and associate professor Henry Lee
speaks quote plastic is hard to break
down you have to add a catalyst to help
break the chemical bonds there's a lot
of hydrogen and plastics which is a key
component for fuel unquote once the
carbon catalyst has done its work it can
be separated out in the next batch of
waste plastic conversion the catalysts
can also be regenerated after losing its
activity after testing several different
catalysts at different temperatures the
best results they obtained was a mixture
of 85% jet fuel and 15% diesel fuel Lee
speaks again quote we can recover almost
a hundred percent of the energy from
plastic we tested the fuel is very good
quality and the byproduct gas is
produced a high quality and useful as
well unquote he goes on to say that this
process is easily scalable it can work
at a large facility or even on farms
where farmers could turn their own
plastic waste into diesel Lee speaks
again quote waste plastic is a huge
problem worldwide this is a very good
and relatively simple way to recycle
these use plastics unquote
another research team at Purdue
University has invented a way to convert
90% of plastic waste into many different
products including pure polymers and
fuels Linda Wang professor at the school
of chemical engineering at Purdue
University speaks quote our strategy is
to create a driving force for recycling
by converting plastic waste into a wide
range of valuable products including
polymers or clean fuels our conversion
technology has the potential to boost
the profits of the recycling industry
and shrink the world's plastic waste
stock encode so going back to the jet
fuel story it's not perfect it's burning
fuel will of course result in greenhouse
gases but it's a big step above what we
have now for those countries who don't
have the environmental awareness and
don't see much issue with throwing
plastic in the ocean it all comes down
to the profit motivation aspect of the
equation if money can be made by
producing plastic waste based fuels this
could be a financial incentive for
government and private companies alike
too heavily recycle and put in place
better methods than landfill and besides
do you want to keep eating increasingly
more amounts of plastic each year I do
encourage the kind of work that these
scientists are doing and hopefully we
can see it implemented on a large scale
soon so really with this video I just
wanted to start a conversation about
this problem and the early solutions
that are being developed it's a real
pity that more people don't know about
this kind of thing
you can help change that by clicking the
share button anyway thanks for watching
this has been - go go and you've been
watching cold fusion don't forget if you
want to check out the podcast versions
of these videos I'll leave a link to
that below alright so I'll see you again
for the next video
cheers guys
have a good one
cold fusion if you thinking
[Music]
you